at the end of the last session Steve we
were talking a little about the way in
which Isaiah encourages a continuous and
over time a long interpretation of the
original articles of Isaiah and Isaiah
himself seems to have been involved in
this kind of interpretation which sets
the pattern for later generations and it
continues certainly all the way down
into the New Testament period they're
reading this material and they're
entering into this great interpretive
tradition that was started by the
Prophet yeah and it continues all the
way into the modern period one if we had
time could track this long history of
the interpretation of this book which
seems to be what the writers of the book
originally intended for us to do so the
next section we're going to take up
begins to talk about Assyria and the
role of a foreign King in determining
Israel's destiny this is a really
unusual idea because it turns out that
God is personally involved in this kind
of activity so do you want to say a
little more about that where does this
idea of using the foreign King as an
agent of some sort where does all this
come from
in the Isaiah tradition well I'm glad
you mention the spot because the
meanings of God using all of these
different instruments or agents in this
book is absolutely fascinating and
there's quite a number as we push
through this series we're going to see
all sorts of figures and nations and
individuals being used as the tool or
instrument or agent of God and to just
try to understand what's going on is
it's quite interesting and to try to see
ourselves and in the role of some of
these agents is interesting certainly
the community of the second Isaiah
thought that it was well worth
considering how this nation of Assyria
which was this militaristic hubristic
violent superpower could possibly be
used by God in God's purposes and just
reading some of this material in
chapters 10 through 12 it really becomes
clear how how arrogant and how full of
themselves this speak this nation of
Assyria was it's one of the things that
second Isaiah is very clear about is
that because God in the view of Isaiah
is this lofty transcendent being of
other nests any human pretensions to
power and arrogance and hubris are just
ridiculous and because Assyria
encapsulate that they they come in for
judgment
so the question gets raised well how can
God both use this power as an instrument
but also judge it at the same time it's
it's really very very interesting the
second Isaiah has a comment on it in
verse 12 of chapter 10 amidst all this
poetry there's a little prose editorial
work and they talk about the work of the
Lord with Assyria being completed it's
the language of God having this plan
this long-range view because God is
transcendent because God is outside of
the cosmos because God is the creator
because God is totally other than what
we are God has this ability to see the
long-range widescreen drama of history
and these agents like Assyria have very
limited and circumscribed roles they
can't destroy God's people for example a
line in the sand is drawn before Zion
before Jerusalem verse 12 says it will
be when the Lord has completed all God's
work on Mount Zion then Assyria is going
to get their punishment so one thing
that emerges is okay the people of the
Lord may go through some very rough
times the water can come up to the neck
but God has a plan and that plan
involves never letting them go under and
never let
down certainly for people today a word
of comfort that God will never let God's
people be dragged under so that all
breath is lost yes it is a word of
comfort and but it Bray it raises
another traditional theme of the second
Isaiah and that is the notion of the
remnant the people who survive are the
remnant and that is a characteristic
notion in Isaiah that the people will
never be wiped out ultimately the idea
of the remnant seems to go back to the
idea of the promise to Jerusalem that it
will never be destroyed this arises in
2nd Samuel 7 where Nathan the Prophet
gives a Oracle of reassurance to David
and promises that his dynasty will be an
eternal dynasty and that God will choose
the City of Jerusalem in perpetuity and
eventually this was transformed in
Israelite thinking into the idea that
the city itself would never be captured
so there is an implicit promise to the
people that there will always be this
remnant in Jerusalem but the important
thing to notice about it is that the
remnant as Isaiah thinks about it does
not get off the punishment in order to
be a part of the remnant you need to go
through the punishment they are the
people who are sitting there with the
water of the Assyrian invasion rising
until it's up to their necks they're
barely able to keep their heads above
water the memorable image that already
is introduced in chapter 6 in the
initial call vision is that this is like
a forest which has been cut down the
remaining wood and the stumps have been
burned yeah but there will from the
stump come up this little sprig of new
life one gets the impression that
is really not much fun to be part of
Isaiah's remnant no I think that's
exactly right and when you get to this
beautiful passage about the stem of
Jesse that we all sing about in Advent
this coming of this messianic sprig
that's going to push itself up in
chapter 11
it really does presuppose this theology
of a remnant it's not like the tree is
growing strong and all of a sudden it
bears new fruit it's a stump the people
of God have been through some awful
trials they've been through an awful
torrent of flooding judgment but out of
that there's this tremendous new life
that's that's going to burst
interestingly enough it's not the
promises to David it's not the Davidic
royal line that's the subject of this
messianic Oracle in Chapter 11 they go
back to Jesse David's father as if to
say we're really going back to the roots
we're really almost digging underground
to find the holy seed way back beyond
everything that David and his children
ever did does that indicate that they're
already having some doubts about the
longevity of the Davidic line when this
is reinterpreted I think you have to
struggle with what what one imagines the
Messiah is if you imagine that the
Messiah is just an affirmation of human
race I just means the vindication of
David's claims to power and all that the
Kings and David's line did then yeah I
think they really need to rethink that
because the god of this material renders
all human claims and pretensions
ridiculous I think they're really trying
to get back when they're when they're
looking at this remnant to just a new
spirituality they're wrestling with that
and part of that new spirituality is
just a new way of being God's vicar on
earth this is a person who isn't judging
by what
his eyes see he is not working by the
normal patterns of power and
administration in the world but
something much more intuitive something
that cares much more about the poor
something that's willing to give the
self a backseat and to be censored on
others
careful concern for the neighbor concern
for the whole community even the weakest
among them it's a in some ways it is a a
critique of traditional royalty
traditional messianic thought it's a new
I think it's a new vision of what it
would mean to have a messiah and what it
would mean to have a remnant organized
around this Messiah so ultimately we can
look forward in the rest of the book
probably to ideas about how that
transformation is going to take place
and what the new Messiah the new royal
personage is going to be yeah I think we
should all keep our eyes open for
exactly that